hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and more specifically welcome back
to the
encyclopedia where today we will be
making our first entry into the world of
manipulation featuring the poster boy of
the art form
one illumi zoldick and look when it
comes to net illumi zoldick is one of
the finest users that we have or ever
we'll see in hunter hunter and i want to
emphasize that right at the beginning
because this isn't always apparent to
more casual readers or watches
going through hunt hunter the first time
around illimi can seem like a very
simple man with straightforward
abilities but the way i would personally
describe
him is a complex figure shrouded by
simplicity there is so
so much more going on under this vacant
stare here that extends to his use of
men as well and furthermore it also
extends to subscribing to the new world
review for regular hunt on to content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
and there is your first revelation right
there i bet that you didn't know illumi
was a subscriber now kindly allow him to
manipulate you into pressing that
wonderful red button as well
don't resist as you'll discover shortly
that probably won't end well for you
before stepping into illimi's trademark
abilities though he is not to be glossed
over in terms of the basics of nen i
think it is very important to highlight
that in terms of sheer aura reserves
illimi has never even come close to
demonstrating his limit to us which is
very impressive given one particular
ability and as much as it's difficult to
judge he is quite consistently portrayed
as something of an equal to hisoka
illimi and hisoka are kind of
aberrations of hunthunter because it's
very difficult to know how to rank
either of them against other legendary
nine users however they do seem to be on
more or less the same plane there is
nothing elimi can do that will really
surprise hisoka and vice versa with that
said illumi is different in one key
aspect which is the basic principle of
ren where hisoka is a more playful
personality illumi
is deadly serious and as so when he
activates ren it has a particular
illusory effect and in the series there
have even been instances when using ren
has led to the impression of facial
distortion like something straight
out of a horror movie because f this in
addition to this illumi's unbridled ren
is so powerful that it can be felt at a
distance of several hundred meters away
which is well there's some pretty potent
bloodlust on display
there and such raw output would make the
zoldic family proud and is actually very
evocative of his grandfather's claim of
being able to project an n up to a
radius of 300 meters
and just as i mentioned in killer's
video i should also state that illimi is
a perfect candidate for nenus having
been thoroughly and brutally trained in
the art of assassination since birth
in terms of physicality he has
absolutely no barriers to men and is
thus free to explore the full potential
of his affinity which speaking of illumi
is a blackheadzoldic child and as is the
trend he was graced with the natural
affinity of manipulation it's a fairly
unfortunate area to land in because it
happens to be right next to
specialization on the nenring meaning
that illumi only has one strong natural
ally in a mission however even that is
arguably more than he needs because all
of his abilities in the series are
attributed as pure manipulation although
i highly doubt that this is the case and
we'll get into why soon but to begin
this examination
in a proper fashion we're going to start
with enemy's most well-known ability
which is corpse control and here we have
an example of manipulation 101 ill me
basically looking for a way to make
other vessels do his bidding and he
achieves this by piercing the head of
any given corpse with a variety of
needles and uses nen
imbued within said needles to issue
commands but this is where i immediately
need to stop and question the idea of
you know
pure manipulation i am fairly convinced
that illumi needs to invoke emission in
order to make
anything to do with these needles work
because the logic is that illumi imbues
the needles with his own aura which in
order to achieve he would need to
separate the aura from his body via a
mission and it's super basic emission
but still it's there and i guess i will
say that this is a long shot of thought
but there is also the potential that
illumi wields conjuration because
it is a friendly enough affinity for him
and it may very well explain how he
possesses seemingly infinite needles you
know he just keeps conjuring them into
existence as needed and from there i
guess the idea would be that the
conjured needles also contain the aura
required to control a body once
initiated but if that wasn't bad enough
i have an even messier explanation which
is that he could conjure the needles
then emit his aura into the conjured
needles and then activate manipulation
once the needles have penetrated the
body in question and i don't think
that's too
out of the realm of possibility for
someone like illumi because he is a
demonstrable master of nan
and neither of the other two affinities
would need to be activated at a
particularly potent degree but you can
also go down another route say that the
needles are physical constructs created
out of raw materials rather than aura
and maybe illumi even dips into
enhancement to make them stronger and
easier to kill people
which speaking of these needles are a
stroke of genius when it comes to corpse
control because this particular ability
can only be used on the dead
and it just so happens that in order to
activate corpse control illumi
essentially needs to kill his target
first with the very needles that then go
on to control them so it's quite a
clever way to efficiently perform this
ability which also takes blatant
advantage of illimi's trained assassin
skills if anyone not trained in swift
death via thin weaponry were to attempt
to use a heart to like this
it would not work out anywhere near as
well for them coop's control is quite
versatile as well because illumi's new
puppets are capable of performing fairly
complex actions and to the untrained eye
they can even pass
for casual living people meaning that
yes it is very good for infiltration and
ambush style uses
all incredibly useful in the assassin
profession the one negative aspect of
corpse control is that it has been
implied that it does take gillamy some
time to craft his puppets and as such
it's not so useful in an emergency style
situation being the ever resourceful man
he is though illimi does have a solution
to this which takes the form of an
ability known as needle people now there
is a common misconception with hunter
hunt fans that this is more or less the
same thing as corpse control
however one of the big differences is
that needle people takes effect on the
living allowing enemy to control people
without killing and converting them and
very importantly this can be achieved
very quickly illumi just needs to stick
a needle that's right just one into the
skull of a person and then
bam control and at this stage you might
be wondering well why even bother using
corpse control then it takes time effort
and involves using many many more
needles and needle people does well
that's because needlepeople comes with a
fair few disadvantages
one of which is that each individual
needle needs to be imbued with a very
substantial amount of aura in order to
gain that instant control and
furthermore once under illumi's command
the needle people become
more or less zombies they aren't capable
of refined action so it's much less
subtle
to uh to say the least although illumi
can choose to insert more needles with
more aura for more complex control but
at that point it would probably be more
efficient just to use corpse control
needle people really is an emergency
situation type of heart suit because it
actively goes against the principles of
assassination because it's not stealthy
in any way shape or form and it just
draws a lot of attention which makes
sense because needle people is very much
a representation of elements in herself
the one he very rarely shows which is a
wildly ambitious and surprisingly
chaotic
persona driven to attain absolute power
and potentially even world domination so
having a heart too structured to control
giant segments of the population is very
much in line with this desire oh and by
the way this
is yet another quality that speaks to
illimi's terrifying oral reserves
making a needle person is not cheap it
requires a significant investment of
aura and the fact that elemy can make
seemingly hundreds at a time while still
possessing enough aura to comfortably
operate himself is
just astonishing and quite possibly the
single most powerful use of manipulation
we've seen in hunter hunter quite
possibly i don't know there's a certain
ant that might be able to trump that but
who cares and dylami certainly doesn't
stop there because the key to being a
great assassin is utility they need to
be able to operate in any given
situation presented
and one other ability that aids illumi
in this regard is body alteration
and this is kind of cool because element
can imbue his needles with aura much
like we've seen already and then insert
them into himself
at which point the aura within will then
go on to manipulate his own body into a
completely different physical structure
and yeah i know this might sound like a
really
roundabout way of doing things you know
emitting aura from your body just to
like reinsert it into your body but
that's kind of just how nen is in fact
manipulation as an affinity is full of
all sorts of crazy subtypings which
means that users more often than not
need to operate in certain conditions
also meaning that they rarely have a
straightforward path of just deciding
something like ah
let's transform my body go yeah it
doesn't really work like that in general
they would need to do it in a more
roundabout way and discovering a
solution under those conditions would
probably lead to their benefit
making the ability either more powerful
or costly sora or something else with
that said to go against
everything i just said illumi is such a
manipulation boss that he can change
his appearance without the use of the
needles but this results in a limited
disguise that he can only use for about
four to five hours before reverting back
and also likely costs him a hell of a
lot more aura to invoke due to not
having as many conditions placed on
activation but illimi also has one other
important hatsu which would of course be
hypnotic spell
also known as retrospectively one of if
not the first visualized depiction of
nen in the series when he activated it
against kilauea in the hunter exam
although to be fair the groundwork for
this ability had been laid long before
that point
hypnotic spell operates quite similarly
to needle people in principle being that
illumi needs to pierce the brain of a
target with a needle however from this
point he not only allows them to live
but also maintain their functions but he
does apply a series of preset commands
or conditions
and there isn't a whole lot of use for
this with the exception of being able to
manipulate the actions of those who
illimic cares about and does not want to
kill
i.e killua and in the series illumi more
or less programmed killerwhat to feel an
overwhelming sense of fear every time he
disobeyed a preset order one of which
would be finding himself in a situation
where he is unsure of victory
because an assassin must always be 100
certain in their success it's also very
subtle and sinister because it's
designed to make their target feel like
these are their real emotions
and willpower itself is not enough to
overcome any feeling generated by
hypnotic spell the only way around it is
to recognize the needle and then remove
it which gillah eventually did and thus
broke free from the spell but this is
also a mark of utility because hypnotic
spell is the only needle technique that
illumi has shown thus far that does not
result in the death or lifelong
crippling of a target
i mean other than the needles that he
uses to control himself of course
and actually i would be really keen to
find out if filament can use his needles
to perform body alteration on anyone
else
but back to an actual point even in the
case of needle people where it's
designed to take control of the living
the heart 2 is also designed to
eventually kill them via over-exhaustion
and in the rare rare case that the
needle person does survive their ordeal
they will be crippled for the rest of
their lives so being controlled by
illumi
is more often than not a death sentence
which is simply terrifying because of
how easy it is for illimi to meet those
activation requirements but in essence
illumi is a master class of manipulation
there are a lot of men users in the
series who splash manipulation to great
effect but there is no one who embodies
the true potential of manipulation like
kilome zelda and in terms of pure
manipulation he makes almost every other
natural manipulator look quite basic in
comparison
even someone like shalnok who is
absurdly powerful in his own right but
illumi is just that amazing that shalnak
looks like budget illumi so let us all
now take a moment to bow before the
undisputed king
of manipulation but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt hunt content then please
to go and check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt on to glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time